did you see this one sister's dating the
same 23-year-old guy oh what man what
does he
smell he smells something bad in there
why would you all marry the same guy
because we both like him does it is it
matter do you why do you I don't
remember asking for your opinion if I
want your opinion I
tell they both turn him shut the [__]
up we tell you do this speaking we tell
you when we talk tell what it is oh my
god oh she cut him off she actually cut
him off does that work go through you
can't groom an adult that's not possible
once again y I know you guys were
saying wait did she just sh
him by the back of his neck [__] up [__]
up down down
down down Charlotte dough BR too and she
doesn't wear a lip plumper either some
people just have really big we not just
bust
ass
not silent but deadly protest yeah
exactly well fine fine if I can't
speak it seems like you guys don't even
like each other well here's the thing
we're crass we're rude we're Rough and
Tumble um she and I were born in the 80s
and I've worked in restaurants over over
20 years one of the reasons why we like
him and he likes us is because we are
not like I'm going to get my tea and I'm
going to drink my tea my sister cuz
you're not
English what did we do last night and
you married ohed go on I've been
married this feels like an animatronic
thing at Disneyland or some [__] like
this like right before we get on a ride
this is like three just things that
speak to each other you know what I mean
it's like welcome to raring Rapids he
likes us cuz we're be sure to get your
Fastpass he likes us cuz we're rough
around the edges and we're not English
he want everyone to blow smoke up his
skirt and um be like a little
jerk and we're just not like that you
know why do you why do you shave your
armpits because he's allergic to his own
body hair yes um why did God let Sandy
Hook
happen
it's a great
question wait was there a comment after
that stop that's just they just
yeah I would assume that's like from a
live and they're refuting the existence
of
God yeah or it's like an Alex
Jones type
thing but that that sentence why did God
let Sandy Hook happen yeah I think they
like oh God's real it's like why did God
let Sandy Hook you oh yeah I see oh cuz
they're atheists right yeah that's I'm
assuming I'm assuming that they are
refuting the existence of God that's a
crazy one to choose though yeah there's
so many other easier things to you know
seriously why did like like how about
this one why did God
allow regular sized ice cubes I mean
that stuff's hard to chew
I kind of like that the boyfriend is
just like an ad lib machine in the
background what's it what's an asexual
version of the
[Laughter]
Migos so stupid that's funny oh my God
the weos yeah yeah the what the I don't
know me no me yeah I don't know me don't
SE don't make me ghost dude put the sexy
red one which one is this which one's
the sexy red one Luke don't even [__]
play games you know who sexy red is wear
they glasses but me baby I'm blind and I
need my glasses so I'm going wear them
I'mma Rock these things oh they're just
people skirts where they they're just
using a clip of her to respond to a
comment oh I see yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm I'm I'm sad for myself that I
can't think of a funny way to spin the
Migos yeah there's got to be there's got
to be something there m
ghosts this is why Tik Tok comments are
misleading because you know [__]
sitting in the comments
like you think so no like when Tik Tok
comments are funny yeah yeah that's what
I'm saying they're all funny yeah but I
know cuz when they're cooking them up
they're sitting there
going yeah yeah and you're saying they
all seem like they're off the D yeah
they all seem like they were just in
Reading hours of thought yeah dude have
you noticed have you
noticed have you noticed a change in
Instagram real comments no no as in the
comments on reals like they used to be
like a [__] cluster [__] cess pool of
just like like YouTube shorts no but now
recently it's like they've kind of done
something to make it more Tik tocky M
where it's like the most upvoted ones
will be at the top and like they like
blow these reals out to like everyone so
they end up being pretty funny but
they're like horribly mean always oh no
always no really no it's gotten to the
point where I've seen people on Tik Tok
as as like a hate comment be like post
this on reals oh and other people are
like no don't do that like don't play
them like that you're right right it's
crazy
I just thought everyone's mean
everywhere I know but it it's something
special going on on Instagram yeah where
they're mean something
special some little special going on
over there special some little extra
hate going on over there no seriously
they did something I don't know what
they
did they turned one of the nozzles you
know how do we upot the most racial
ones we would like the most racially
charged comments the top more hate more
hate should be more hate
suppress yeah I don't know yeah I just
tore my
ACL I'm
in can you look up synonyms for
asexuality are you still still looking
what Amigo saying yeah AA
atic the hell you just said
atic what is the what is the second one
genetic agamo genetic far Gamo
genetics designer genetics so that is
the actual guy of the week yeah the
middle dude yeah that's the guy of the
week right
there one of
them why did God let Sandy Hook happen
yeah yeah
yeah she said go she said he's allergic
to his own body hair that's
yeah dude haircuts must be horrible yeah
seriously it's [__] or they must be
good no but I mean when it's growing
back oh yeah it's got to be that itchy
State it's always growing back though
yeah so how what isn't body I guess does
head on hair count as body hair I I
don't know no no no I mean he had a full
head of hair yeah he did maybe he's just
always itchy it's crazy how they talk
about him like he's like like a dog I
know he just he's a you know he's
allergic to his own body hair we had to
stop eting chicken
we feed him lamb now strictly dry food
he gets groomed twice a
month that's why he's always itchy cuz
they never let him think of
yeah